実ああもうバイトがー
もう閉めなんでー
ちょっと何か
なんかなんかなんかに分かるこの外国に行く前の
変な素案と恐怖というか
本当にキレイ事でハブられたらどうするとか考えちゃってあんまり寝れません
外れ社長ですローソンには本当にお世話になって
いっぱいとを得ることができそうですありがとうございます
というわけで今日はですねセブンイレブンで買ってきました
富士山ラムネです
あちなみにこれは猫ねみんな大好きなから魔法少女まどかマギカの
なんかフィギュアがローソンにあったルーズ16車買ったらついてきたのでぜひね御岳
の皆さんは勝ってください
まあたまには昼バーまあこういうラムネずっとがもういい夏ってこの開ける時が
チョイスんですよ
見てくださいねん
まあ僕はプロなんでそんなことはしません泳いで行ってきも壊せませんから
も母艦も僕は僕もよ
暗着色料多いこれを得ない事由者
したくねぇ
踏まえ
この便自体がなんか
日本一を置きらしいんですよてがまだ実は保険ものが入ってなくて海外保険
そういうのもちょっと急がなきゃいけなくて後携帯の配役をしなきゃいけないんだ
天田学校のレポート終わってねえや何もしてないんですけどそれでは外国に行くという
かな
僕の
強さですこれ日本的なものの行き交いもそんなになくなってくるんじゃないかなと思っ
てね
偶にはこういうローカルなものもねこれじゃあもん食べます
富士山鍋って書いてあるけど市蔵子つかしか売ってないと思うんで
皆さんは買えませんごめんなさいって言うけど物をへ
学校となぁ
入学の済み頑張っていきますじゃあ
me